they asked me are you knowingly going
against gavin newsom's orders and i said
yes on december 3rd 2020 governor gavin
newsom ordered all california
restaurants to stop serving customers in
person and convert their businesses to
take out only stem the tide bend the
curve this is not a permanent state it
was the third shutdown order of the
pandemic
annie rammel who owns the oak and elixir
restaurant in the san diego beach town
of carlsbad decided that she had enough
these restaurants are staying open in
the form of a peaceful protest keeping
their doors open to try to financially
survive when the same person that's
telling you and restricting you from
being open is going to a restaurant
himself and eating inside it puts a
little fire in you this isn't right i'm
going to stand up for my rights i'm
going to stand up for my business that i
worked extremely hard
to to run and to have
and i'm going to stand up for the
community i deeply empathize and i have
deep appreciation for the stress and the
struggles our restaurants have had i
remember watching his press conference
and he said it was going to be three
weeks i told restaurant owners you're
not smart if you think this is only
gonna be three weeks it's definitely
gonna be months and i was right several
decided that they would also defy the
governor's order they formed a coalition
of restaurants and retail businesses
that eventually numbered in the hundreds
we opened up and it was crazy because we
were really the only city that was doing
this
outspokenly the village in carlsbad
looked like this friday evening outdoor
patios bustling with customers looking
to keep their favorite local spots alive
during this pandemic and restaurants
like oak and elixir happily serving them
despite the latest regional stay-at-home
order we were going to continue to be
safe we're going to continue to wear
masks and sanitize and six feet apart
and do everything that we had been doing
before but that we were not going to
close down that we were going to
continue to allow people to come to our
restaurant and sit on at our tables and
eat ramo was issued a citation by san
diego's public health department and by
the state alcohol board which threatened
to revoke her liquor license but the
county sheriff had decided not to
enforce the governor's order one of the
first nights we reopened against gavin
newsom's orders the sheriff started
walking by and i remember my heart
pounding because i'd heard these rumors
that they were arresting people and
taking them away and i knew that if it
would come down to that that for me it
was worth it the police department
actually came by and they did give us a
piece of paper that was documenting that
i was going against the orders they said
we just want you to know that we don't
want to be doing this
we we want you guys to survive this
we're sorry
as they're handing me the paper today
the coalition that defied the governor's
orders is suing newsome and their state
and local health departments to drop the
fines and compensate for the losses
incurred by the shutdowns the defendants
in the case declined to comment for this
story if they prevail it could have
implications for what the scope of
executive power truly is in a state of
emergency underground regulations
facilitate arbitrary enforcement and
they undermine the rule of law attorney
matt harrison represents the san diego
county business owners he was also a
former senior fellow at the reason
foundation the non-profit that publishes
reason tv
harrison says newsome's emergency orders
didn't follow the proper procedure for
issuing new regulations one of the most
canonical established
applications of due process
is that the law needs to be clear clear
enough so that a person a reasonable
person can understand what's prohibited
and what's allowed we look to a
blueprint
for safely reopening the economy
harrison says this plan wasn't legally
binding because the governor didn't
follow the correct legal procedure
regulations in california are required
to be submitted to the secretary of
state who then makes them available for
a public review process regulations also
have to be accompanied by an explanation
for why they're justified it's the rules
for the rulemakers it's the regulations
for the regulators the state argues that
the governor was able to prevent the
procedure because he was issuing
emergency orders during a public health
crisis
and whether it stands is whether due
process exists in emergencies in the
state
ramall says that despite the governor's
mantra the regulations didn't follow the
science with regard to covet spread
there was no proof that the outbreaks
were coming from us
we felt like we were keeping people safe
for months rammel and the coalition lost
the first round when a san diego
superior court judge dismissed the
coalition's lawsuit the case is now
before an appeals court courts have
recently demonstrated a willingness to
strike down administrative actions that
circumvent standard rule-making
procedures several trump administration
actions were struck down including one
that would have added a census question
about citizenship status one that would
have changed deportation procedures and
an executive order that would have
allowed employers to opt out of certain
birth control insurance coverage ramall
says the fines she still faces for
refusing to follow the governor's order
amount to a couple thousand dollars and
don't threaten her livelihood but this
isn't a fight about money our rights
are being tested and that's scary
because we live in america where we're
supposed to be free and we're supposed
to be able to have our rights and make
the choice to be open and i think that's
being threatened right now
[Music]